if you're a fan of Metal Gear creator
Hideo Kojima you know he has a soft spot
for movies and now we've learned his
thoughts on the recent ghost in the
shell live-action adaptation i'm tony
and this is your anime inspired gamespot
news update Kojima wrote up his thoughts
in an essay on Rolling Stones game
website lixil and while he praised the
movies loyalty to the original his words
aren't all positive he wrote the respect
that the movie shows in mimicking the
anime is unquestionable as a real fan of
the original works though I can't help
but feel that the production was trapped
in the shell of the original and as a
result it fails to come into its own
upon leaving the theater and returning
to the real world the characters stay
behind locked in their shell unable to
break free kojima's next work is death
stranding which is headed to ps4 and PC
at some point in the future be sure to
LIKE and subscribe to stay up to date on
that and for more ghost in the shell
discussion you can check out our own
breakdown over on gamespot universe
you